okay and right at the beginning of
mechanics I showed you this right I said
okay look suppose you have a weight
right I'm you have an object with mass
and it's suspended on a string okay and
if it rotates around like this
you've got tension in the string your
gravity on it as well okay and the shape
that this thing traces out is this
current right let's call the conical
pendulum because the thing that's
actually moving around is a pendulum and
it's not really a current like we're
just imagining in the current that's
there okay so since you're not
generalizing we're gonna put a whole
bunch of labels on this and because I
think about forces and multiple
dimensions are like I think there's
gonna be a lot so try not to get
overwhelmed right so here's where we're
going to begin there is a particle P
okay that's what particle P it's
sometimes also called a bob thanks for
your know Roberts in this cost of anyway
particle Bob whatever it is suspended on
the end of the street it has a mass of M
kilos I'll write that down massive in
kilos and the length of this string can
call that L for length okay so I'm gonna
do that this color okay so that like
this L meters right it's just suspended
from this fixed point up here
okay would it be naturally called F for
fixed but that's forces we've been
actually P for point that that's
particle so qualitex we said you say you
see I have no idea just let's call it
that okay fixed point up there where its
suspended from we have an angular
velocity of Omega but he's the problem
let me that make it like I'm trying to
like before make this diagram as simple
as possible I suppose if you were to put
my makeup on this diagram it would be
here
right going for actually maybe even here
going around okay because it's the
change in angle right so what we've got
here that's the origin around which
you've got this circle of course it
doesn't look circular right now because
we're looking at it from this
perspective but if we looked at it top
down you get a circle okay because the
axis the sorry the plane of this circle
is horizontal we call it a horizontal
circle it's a bit of a weird phrase like
the circles on the same attempt the way
they go but it's talking about the plane
that is sitting on all right what are
the person pieces do we need you've got
a sense are we need a radius so here's a
radius R meters from the center to the
extremities of the mission and now I
want to pose three questions and they're
all going to be in general two first
trains and then he created me at 12
girls okay
here are the three questions that I want
to ask firstly what's what's the tension
in the street this question gets posed
to you all the time what is T for
tension can we evaluate it in terms of
all this stuff it's here okay secondly
this table that's warmed up here right
this angle between the vertical and the
stream okay
what is that angle and what does it
depend on what makes that angle you can
actually start to anticipate this what
makes that angle you know quite small
like it's a narrow conical pendulum or
what makes that angle really really why
okay what does it depend on what
quantities of things you can start to
anticipate
so second thing we're gonna look for is
an expression for theta find a question
find a question what's the height of
this whole system how far how far is the
center of the circular motion from the
point that the string is suspended on
what's this height okay so this is the
question now where are we going to begin
as we usually do with a mechanic's
question is we want to work out where
all the forces are okay now you really
will need a few more colors here right
the first easiest kind of force to worry
about is gravity gravity is always
pretty much the same it's always going
from the particle by other forces are
gonna be sent it to you from the
particle downward that's fine okay
actually I should do it now what will
the force of gravity be in this
situation
I've got masam kilos gravity's not to
fire for you is nine point eight or ten
we can just call it G so the magnitude
of this force will be empty simple
enough okay so that fits easy but then
what's the other main force at play here
and where would it go on the diagram
it's going to be this this tension in
the string that I'm trying to find okay
now where is this tension where would be
a helpful place to illustrate right well
it has to come is acting on the particle
right so I'm going to start from here
and it's going in the direction of back
up to wherever the stream is fixed okay
so I have for instance I might do it
like that so do not confuse this tension
with the whole length of the stream it's
just the force pulling in that same
direction the string is pulling now
where are we going to need to do work is
to say well what are the forces on the
particle that are the forces right so
start with the simple one what is the
vertical force on it now I'm thinking
about the resultant force resultant
force survey how far is it moving up and
down as the as time progresses answer
it's not moving up or down at all it's
just moving in this horizontal circle
it's just staying in this plane
okay so verdigris there is no motion
okay what that tells you is that this
downward force McGarrett gravity must be
counteracted by an equal and opposite
upward force right where does that come
from
it comes from this tension because this
tension is offered a direction so
there's going to be a vertical part and
there's going to be a horizontal part so
let's try those
okay so now that we have at least
visually we resolve these forces okay we
need to use a bit of geometry to work
out one of the magnitude of those forces
we've got their directions handle there
but I don't know how big they are
okay so we'll do the same trick that we
did with the circle on the corner plane
before you've got thinner up here right
which means that thiness should be we
should be yeah it's got you've got
ultimate angles here don't use right so
you've got it yeah
no there okay and that means you also
have it just have corresponding angles
then she said okay so that means in this
triangle here which is right-angled okay
I want to know what's the magnitude of
this vertical force okay it's adjacent
it's adjacent here this is the
hypotenuse okay so you can probably
anticipate with done Christians like
this before what is this going to be
every t cos theta right because cos
theta is adjacent on hypotenuse so you
multiply through by the hypotenuse which
is T so that's T because feedom okay in
exactly the same way you can realize
that same argument horizontally you're
gonna get T sine theta okay excellent
now let's come back to why we were
talking about vertical horizontal in the
first place
hussein is no motion right so you're
this downwards this upwards they must be
exactly equal to each other in magnitude
anyway okay so that means nothing like
this
so far so good okay horizontally what's
happening obviously something much more
interesting right horizontally because
it's a horizontal sector there is motion
what kind of motion is this it's uniform
circular motion okay so that means I can
say that this inward force like this arm
this t sine-theta
what's it equal to it should be it
should be we've worked this out right
the force the centripetal force back to
on the center it's M R Omega squared
right there just a little point of
reference here mmm equipment that's your
resultant force on the particle in this
horizontal plane okay but you mustn't
muscle mustn't put em on meet you square
on your diagram here's why okay in this
case it just so happens that these are
exactly the same okay because this is
the only force pulling it back toward
the center but in other cases in an
example I'm going to show you at ten
minutes it's not like that right there
are other forces of play and they all
add up together to produce this this is
the resultant force so being that it is
not actually a physical thing it's not
tension it's not gravity it's what
happens when you add up a whole bunch of
other forces you don't put it on your
diagram okay you can put this and this
and this they're all gooey okay
but this is what happens when you add up
all of those okay so far so good what
should i do at this point what can I do
where am I headed towards I mean it's
the first question asking for tension
what would you do
once I know my someone got suggestions
for what I should know we call this one
equation one equation what do I do with
multiply this by cause multiply this by
sine okay what's that going to do you're
going to get cos squared sine squared
that's kind of Handy isn't so let's
let's try that out
okay one times cos plus 2 times sine
okay so let's check along with this what
are you going to get over here you're
gonna have to close squared feet up and
then you're gonna have em G close see
them yep
oh here you'll get T sine squared okay
so you can see your cos squared and your
science fair you're gonna come together
you'll get T over here and that gives
you this
okay now I think we can push a little
further on this we can pressure the
office the reason why is because theta
huh
right this is all true by the way
there's nothing wrong with it but I
don't know what theater it is I know I
haven't got to them yet right so even
though this is true number one it's a
different mass number two it has an
unknown in it that I'm kind of stuck
with right now what I do know in this
situation which is very closely related
is I know what L is I know what L is
they are in the same triangle together
sir apart from this line here
see that's fine but can I come up with
something more helpful in terms of
things I actually know rather than
things that I don't know